hey guys welcome back we have Josh we're
back we're back thanks for coming back I
always look like Josh comes to town
because I get all the - yeah
alright big brother let's do it let's
are you ready for this cuz I'm not gonna
hold back with my questions now listen
I've been waiting for our interview to
go in so really yeah okay let's stop
with this season how do you feel about
this season so far I obviously think so
it started out rough obviously there was
a lot of controversial things going on
and I think it's picked up and the top
four I feel like they're all deserving
they've all played sort of a unique game
that got on there so I think they're all
deserving in the wind Jackson's move
what do you think about it I respect the
move at the end of the day he's doing
whatever it takes to win yeah he had his
girl on the line and he's gonna do
whatever it takes to save her and that
move itself deserves a win like I don't
even know how he came up with that so
quick but that was that was awesome to
watch so who do you think is the most
deserving to win this season because you
touched on that Justin it really isn't
your favorite but that move was so like
I think not only the move he's been in a
huge Alliance been a huge target since
the beginning and he's been able to stay
- what day 80-something top 4 so I think
he's proved that he's playing like a
strategic or social and a physical game
so he is completely deserving of the win
but I want Nakota win why I love Nicole
1 she's the underdog she's kind of like
you know they overlooked her she's been
the underdog of the whole time she kind
of laid low she's played her card her
cards right with cliff also I feel like
they've won when they had to set back
and like didn't really like you know
cause much chaos and just let everybody
else pick each other off so she's been
doing something right I mean to make it
to that point you made it we made it
that far so we know that it's not unless
you're a complete voter and I don't
think neither of them are yeah so yeah I
like her as a person personally but I
like her her game also who would you
want to win Jackson or Nicole
because winner of Big Brother who do you
think should win this you're gonna
disagree with me okay go okay okay so
I'm rooting for before I get heat for
this I want cliff Endicott rooting for
Anna colder cliff but deserving most
deserving I think Jackson I think
because they're gonna drag you I think
his social game has been great you know
I think the way that he exposes social
listen he exposed he exposed Tommy just
with that move itself yeah that was like
a maverick move yeah he doesn't care
he's ruthless and he's doing whatever it
takes to win he got there was with his
romance was able at the right time
switch alliances and partner up with
cliff and Nicole which was huge at that
point in the game instead of sticking
with his numbers he flipped which that's
why I think he's at the end right now
yeah because of that Alliance that they
formed at the end so I think he's done
everything right he's he has a good
pulse and a good read on the on the game
and he's played it awesome I think to
kick it with him and drink a beer with
me and give me a guy with him no boy I
respect the game yeah you got to respect
the game I will say this I feel like
when it comes to Jackson I wish I liked
him so I could stand that move that he
just did because Big Brother players
when comes to big bro that's a great big
brother move yeah I will agree with you
a little tiny bit and now okay America's
favorite player who do you think's going
to take it I don't know I know me right
I don't know you got Nicole you got
productions pushing for cliff I feel
that right yeah we say yes they want
cliff and I look I would want cliff to
to win it and I think chemi that's like
the top three so I don't know who's
gonna win it but either would you want
to weigh I would want cami to win it
that's just like the biggest slap in the
crush
no joke and you know what she does she
would have deserved that wind she was
she would and I was rude it would be
such a great leg slap in the face oh
yeah all right before I let you go talk
about Christi and Tommy for a second
Christi you know it's crazy I'm gonna
try to be nice
no I'm not gonna be nice that's great
Sorry Sorry
I think you know the thing with Tommy
and Christi is they played hard they
played a good game I got to give him
props to that but I think that you know
Christi doesn't come off as genuine at
all and I think there was not one tear
coming out of that girl's eye like she
never dropped a tear so it was just for
me it felt very forced yeah um Tommy
played a great game I got nothing back
to say about his game I just personally
them they talked about about me all the
time on the fees what oh my god I don't
even want to they were dragging you
every day every time they said my name
they were just going oh that's why
Victor backed about yeah they were
talking about me winning all this stuff
so I'm like you know but you still
flopped that it's all yeah but no I mean
they played a good game I just don't
like them I couldn't have a crispy no I
couldn't live with Christi and the
crying I know you tried your season yeah
I'm like I'm just gonna solid cried
every day to live in the dr i cried
everything stop giving me just keep
trying no please
it's it's it's it's tough in there you
know you pride i i send you adrift on um
a gif on twitter of you will cut her
some slack you're still a winner a title
that not many people could say that they
have and i love hearing your thoughts
and the season because you're so
unfiltered so I'm glad you came and you
know sat with us here in Canada and
talked to us about your thoughts on
season 21